so as the left is trying to radically
change our politics they're gaslighting
the Sun okay we saw this we see this
with the mask order CNM is kind of let
it letting the mask slip a little bit
actually pun very much intended they
came out with an article yesterday
called
the psychology behind why some people
won't wear masks look at that word
psychology it's not why people won't
wear masks it's not the rational reasons
why people have political disagreements
it's not the reason why some people are
interpreting the scientific evidence to
realize that there's not a huge threat
when you're at a wide-open space and
you're a young person and you don't have
other comorbidities right
uh-huh it's the psychology behind why
some people don't this this goes back to
what liberals were saying in the middle
of the twentieth century about
conservatives they said that
conservatism was just a series of
irritable mental gestures that that
sought to give the impression of real
thought it was just irritable mental
gestures and that's what they're saying
here CNN is interviewing a bunch of
doctors a bunch of physicians to tell us
when we can reopen they're interviewing
a bunch of psychologists to try to
explain why people have different
political points of view as though
people don't have their own faculties of
reason as if if you voted for anybody
who's not a leftist if you in any way
disagree with leftist policies then
you've got to have something wrong with
your psychology
never mind by the way that the left was
telling us these very doctors were
telling us three weeks ago not to wear
masks the Surgeon General three
exclamation points don't wear masks then
two seconds later they say you have to
wear masks forget that that would be my
maybe a part of my reason why I don't
think I need to wear a mask all the time
but no it's the psychology something's
got to be wrong in your head this can
all be explained by the dictatorship of
science history politics it's all a
matter of science put the guys in the
white lab coats in charge they all
coincidentally happen to be leftists and
then let them run your lives for you
very pathetic
[Music]